and welcome to Hannity history on
Capitol Hill tonight eight Republican
lawmakers joining all 208 house
Democrats to remove Kevin McCarthy as
house Speaker the first time in our
nation's history and McCarthy will not
seek the speakership again now sources
telling me at this hour some House
Republicans have been in contact with
and have started an effort to draft
former president Donald Trump to be the
next speaker and I have been told uh
that uh president Trump might be open to
helping the Republican party at least in
the short term if necessary uh if it's
needed anyway but here's former speaker
McCarthy earlier tonight let's take a
look I believe I can continue to fight
maybe in a different manner I will not
run for speaker
again I'll have the conference pick
somebody else I think today was a
political decision by the Democrats and
I think I think the things they have
done done in the past hurt the
institution when they just started
removing people from committee when they
just started doing the other things and
I my fear is the institution fell
today because you can't do the job if
eight people you have 94% of or 96% of
your entire conference but eight people
can partner with the whole other
side how do you govern and for them to
make a motion on me because I made a
decision for the country that they
agreed with but they choose to do the
other that becomes a
problem now this all went down after a
motion to vacate was put forward by
Florida Congressman Matt Gates citing
trust issues because of a recent
bipartisan resolution a CR to fund the
government through mid November and a
lack of action on a number of bills
Appropriations bills and Gates went
forward with a move to Al speaker
McCarthy successful anyway given the
slim GOP majority Gates needed only a
handful of other Republicans to get it
done but now uncertainty Reigns Supreme
on Capitol Hill in truth Gates other
Republicans they did have legitimate
complaints returning to regular order
passing Appropriations bills single
issue bills balanced budget amendment
term limits all promised Fair criticism
but many of those measures could have
been dealt with especially in the future
especially issues that would never have
become law at this time really came down
to the fiscal issues in at in play here
the Appropriations process for example
but the question is this and every
conservative every Republican needs to
be asking this tonight was this the best
strategic and tactical Approach at this
moment now there were very very viable
Alternatives plans put together by
Freedom caucus members people like
Congressman chip Roy who will join us
tonight and Byron Donalds and Scott per
carry for example one plan cut uh from
them cut spending by a whopping 8% and
also had historic border security
measures attached but was opposed by
Gates and a few other Republicans and
that didn't go far that left chip Roy
kind of speechless that plan would have
allowed more time needed for the
Appropriations bills to be passed and
the SE second option actually had a 30%
cut in discretionary spending and
included by the way the Republic of
party's border bill hr2 that would have
been a great alternative that again
would have also resulted in the full 12
Appropriations bills having been voted
on and hopefully passed so today the
question we all have was the nuclear
option needed was it worth it well I can
tell you right now I don't know time
will certainly tell whether this is a
good move or a bad move but one reality
will not change Republicans have a
minuscule majority whoever the speaker
is and it is made up of disparate groups
ranging moderate left to Freedom caucus
conservative now Gates says that he was
ripping the Band-Aid off the status quo
in the Washington swamp but the house
oversight committee chairman Jim Jordan
had a different take let's hear him on
January 3rd we said the 118th Congress
is about three things pass the bills
that need passed do the oversight work
that needs to be done and stop the
inevitable Omnibus that comes from the
United States Senate right before the
holidays Kevin McCarthy has been Rock
Solid on all three we have passed the
bills we told the American people we
would pass 87,000 IRS agents that bill
that bill passed parents Bill of Rights
that bill passed energy legislation
passed border security immigration
enforcement legislation the strongest
bill ever to pass the Congress passed
earlier this year we have done what we
told them we were going to do all right
now keep in mind Republicans hold a N9
vote majority and 1/ half of onethird of
the federal government
uh making up that very slim majority as
a coal Coalition of lawmakers you got
the freedom caucus the Tuesday Thursday
Friday Sunday group the study group
along with moderate Republicans many
from districts that Biden won in 2020 18
to be exact now bringing that group
together on anything is not an easy feat
but in the end Republicans let me warn
you tonight you will succeed or you will
fail together that is undeniable still
McCarthy accomplished a lot including a
serious investigation into Biden's
bribery money laundering allegations
which is ongoing an impeachment inquiry
that is now picking up steam an
investigation into Biden's weaponized
FBI and doj multiple major pieces of
legislation including a border security
bill that I just mentioned a bill to
stop Biden's plan to hire 80,000 new IRS
agents a bill to stop big government
restrictions on gas stoves and other
appliances another bill to repeal the
worst parts of the so-called inflation
reduction act and that's just the tip of
the iceberg but now without a speaker
all matters involving the house come to
a grinding halt the gop's investigations
will be stalled zero Republican bills
will be sent to the Senate and
Republican infighting that'll take
Center Stage which is exactly what
Democrats and the media mob desperately
want and they want to continue for a
long period of time now president Trump
earlier today even in the midst of
what's going on in New York took time to
post this on Truth social why is it that
Republicans are always fighting among
themselves why aren't they fighting the
radical left Democrats who are
destroying our country well I happen to
agree with the president we are now a
year away from the single most pivotal
election of our lifetime it's all on the
line now Democrats are destroying the
rule of law equal justice equal
application of our laws is dead and uh
by the way as we've seen Donald Trump
and his family are now being targeted in
ways this country has never seen before
Joe Biden and his family are shielded
protected around every turn by Joe's
weaponized doj the border is an absolute
disaster nightmare National Security
risk our economy is a disaster Americans
are suffering more than at any point in
my lifetime inflation is through the
roof gas prices are through the roof and
going higher by the way and our
commanderin-chief has real significant
cognitive issues that everybody in the
world can see because it's that
transparent he is neither physically nor
mentally fit to serve this country House
Republicans can can't solve their
differences behind closed doors how
about you get in a room you throw away
your phone and uh maybe you stay in that
room order pizza and don't come out
until you agree knowing how important
these Appropriations bills were I have a
criticism Why did Republicans take off
the month of August in the end this may
all turn out fine I'm not hitting the
panic button tonight however the
American people's patience it will run
out quickly here and so the GOP take my
advice if you want it seems a lot of
people never take it be careful and you
better get a new speaker quickly
Democrats they want you in complete
disarray they want a distraction away
from their fail policies and their
feeble president and they'd really love
a few moderate Republicans to peel off
off and actually vote for a Democrat for
speaker so will the GOP rally behind the
new speaker will anyone even want the
job or will this end in a disaster I
cannot answer that question tonight but
time will tell we expect to vote on a
new speaker sometime next week hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else